hello in this video i explain
what a logistic regression is and
how you can calculate it online
and we start with that right away in the
previous videos we went through the simple
linear and the multiple linear
regression here the
dependent variable was a metric
variable in this one  video is about
logistic regression here the
dependent variable is a categorical
variable let's say you want to
predict whether or not a person is prone to
burnout
you want to make this prediction by asking
about the person's highest level of education the number of hours worked each
week
and age  the person because the
variable whether a person is at
risk of burnout or not is a
categorical variable you must use a
logistic revision
the logistic recession is a
special case of regression analysis and
is calculated when a dependent
variable scales nominally
or originally escalates  t is
let's look at three
examples here for an online retailer
you are supposed to predict which product
a particular customer will buy first
this keeps its record of
previous visitors and their
purchases this requires a logistic
regression since your dependent variable
is buys  the person yes or no
the second example from medicine you
want to investigate whether a person
is susceptible to a certain disease yes
or no here you have a
data set with sick and non-
sick people as well as other
medical parameters again for this
you need a logistical recession
because your  dependent variable is categorical
is a person susceptible yes or
no to a certain disease and
the last example from politics
would a person vote for a party yes or
no if elections next weekend
would be again a categorical
dependent variable with the answers yes
and no
so still  now what is a
logistic recession
in the basic form of the logistic
recession, the atomic variables can be forecast
with values ​​0 or 1 or yes
or no
for this the
probability of the occurrence of the
value 1 characteristic is estimated
in medicine is a common goal, for example
to find out which variables have an
influence on a disease, in
this case 0 could stand for not
ill and one for ill and
it is examined what influence
age, gender and smoking
status have on this particular disease
, so let's look at this again
graphically  we have the
independent variables age gender
smoking status and with these three
variables we want to predict whether
a person is susceptible to a certain
disease or not so the
dependent variable is does this person have
this disease yes or no
so now you are probably asking yourself the
question and  what do we need  I'm allowed to do
a logistic recession now why ca
n't we just use a linear
regression for that a quick look
back at the linear region is
that our recession equation we
have a dependent variable that is zero
or one so it doesn't matter
what value like with the independent
variables we have  always get
either zero or one out we will
now use a linear
regression we will simply
insert a linear straight line into these points
the graphic shows that values ​​between
plus and minus of finite can now
occur so it can be that there are
values ​​plus infinity and  -
can occur
indefinitely the aim of the logistic region is
to estimate the probability of occurrence and not the value of the
variable so we want to know is it
more like 0 or is it more like one the
range of values ​​for the prediction is limited to
the range between 0 and
1 so only  values ​​between 0
and 1 possible  are the so-called
logistic function is used therefore
the logistic model is based on the
logistic function what is special about
the logistic function is that for the
values ​​between minus and plus
infinity only values ​​between 0 and 1
come out
so no matter where we are here on the x  -axes
are between -
finally only values ​​between zero and one come
out and that is exactly what we
want
the equation for the logistic
function now looks like this we have 1
multiplied by one plus - counts this
set we now set our usual  equation
for the region so the
equation below where b1 bka are the recession
coefficients of the point and x1
to xk are the variables we
used that our logistic
functions look like this now of
course we have to tune the coefficients b1 and
pepe so that our model  best
depicts the data that we
have available
, we have now made sure
that it doesn't matter  in which area dix
value is only numbers between
0 and 1 come out the new graph looks like
this when we
look at our example
we want to know the probability
that a person is sick so
we just put in our  model 1
b1 times the age plus b2 for the
sex plus for 3 x the smoking
status and the on point now we have to
determine b1 b2 b3 and so that we
map the data as well as possible
this is done with the so-called maximum
light method for this there is
good numerical solution that solves the
problem for you so you
usually just use a statistics program
and the program gives the values
1 b2 b3 and ahaus i'll show you
the values ​​again with the data tab
you can get them directly online so we'll
go again  click on date up de on
the statistics calculator
if you like you can copy your
own data here i
use simp  oh
let's do the example now let's just click on regression
and as soon as you apply a dependent
variable that is categorical it will
automatically calculate a logistic regression
it doesn't make much sense now
but let's say you want
to predict the company a
person works at then click  you
simply do what is a categorical
variable and as independent
variables we simply take the
income and age of a person
and then you get the
results for the logistical recession down here
our dependent variable has three characteristics
bmw daimler and
vw you can traditionally  in a
model of a logistical recession
, only ever use dependent variables with two characteristics
, so we make
three models here,
the first model asks if it's bmw, the
second model asks if it's daimlers and
the third model asks if it's svw and
here we see then  the results for
the prediction vo  n bmw with the
coefficients here you could, if you
like, enter your own values
to make a prediction
then we will see the model for the predictions
from daimler and the model for the
prediction from vw so you can see
it’s really easy i would say
try it  just turn it off yourself
and see you next time